[Música]
hoy en directo Vamos hasta Bolivia
porque en el día 34 de huelga en la
ciudad de Santa Cruz los manifestantes
aceptaron que el censo de población se
realice en 2024 esto debido a motivos
técnicos no obstante exigieron que la
realización de esta medición poblacional
quede estipulada en una ley la cámara ya
debate la iniciativa pero falta que pase
al senado para ampliar los detalles de
esta información conectamos con merivaca
corresponsal de Franz 24 en La Paz Mary
qué es lo que ha ocurrido durante esta
jornada la número 34 del paro
Qué tal Buenas noches bueno durante esta
jornada luego de que los líderes de la
protesta de Santa Cruz aceptaran que el
censo de población y vivienda se realiza
en el año 2024 como venía pidiendo el
presidente Luis Arce la comisión de
Constitución de la cámara de diputados
se ha dado la tarea de concertar un
único proyecto de ley para llevarlo al
pleno de la cámara de diputados este
proyecto de ley va a establecer dos
cosas uno que el reparto de recursos
económicos con base en la nueva realidad
demográfica de Bolivia se realice a
partir de septiembre del año 2024 y que
la redistribución de escaños
parlamentarios también con los nuevos
datos censales se produzca antes de las
elecciones generales del año 2025 tal
como piden los opositores y los líderes
de la protesta de Santa Cruz una vez que
este proyecto termine de ser concertado
en la comisión lo cual podría suceder en
los próximos minutos u horas va a pasar
al lleno de la cámara de diputados que
ya está convocada para sesionar esta
misma noche para aprobar lo antes
posible el proyecto de ley sin embargo
la gran incógnita es si es que se van a
lograr o no los votos necesarios para
aprobar este proyecto de ley Pues existe
una persona en Bolivia que está en
contra de este proyecto y es el ex
presidente Evo Morales quien tiene una
bancada todavía fuerte en la cámara de
diputados y en la cámara de senadores y
él y sus diputados y senadores han dicho
que van a votar en contra de este
proyecto de ley no quieren que se haga
una norma para el censo porque
consideran que eso le restaría autoridad
al presidente Luis Arce por eso todavía
no se sabe si esta ley va a llegar a
buen término en ambas cámaras Mary Cómo
se ha visto impactada la economía
boliviana con esta huelga que además no
se detiene Va a continuar
Así es el impacto es grande porque hay
que tomar en cuenta que Santa Cruz es la
locomotora económica de Bolivia la mayor
parte de las exportaciones no
tradicionales salen de ese departamento
y muchos de los alimentos que se
consumen en Bolivia también se producen
en aquella región según un cálculo del
propio gobierno se pierden alrededor de
40 millones de dólares cada día Y eso
significa que a estas alturas con 34
días de paro estaríamos en una pérdida
de alrededor de 1.300 millones de
dólares para la economía del país por
otro lado la ciudad está sufriendo por
el paro si bien la gente está cumpliendo
firmemente con la medida también se
impide por ejemplo la circulación de
bicicletas y hoy día la empresa que
recoge la basura estaba pidiendo
encarecidamente que dejen pasar a los
carros basureros porque ya Existen dos
mil toneladas de basura repartidas en la
ciudad de Santa Cruz sin que pueda
votarse en el vertedero como verás esta
afectación económica que está ocurriendo
desde Santa Cruz también le llega al
resto del país porque la economía
boliviana está muy ligada a lo que
suceda en la ciudad de Santa Cruz